I completed my graduation in 2021 at
Peak of covid-19 it was hard to find a
job making full-time career in software
development was harder but upskilling
helped me grab an amazing job offer last
year I joined HL Tech as a software
engineer now I'm aing 50% more than what
I used to
get hi I'm as sag I live in godson
country Kera I started off as a graphic
designer I did few internship in graphic
designing and videoed but it was not
what I want to make a career with I was
such more IND in software development I
got a chance to work as a web developer
with NIS Foundation last year it was
part time but all it did was F my
passion for software development I
wanted to stand out from the crowd and
to learn mean stack during my research I
found that simply learn was the one of
the very few platform providing courses
in mean stack development I found the
platform better than its competitor and
decided to enoll Simply lens curriculum
occupied me with crucial tools like aen
gin and foundational Cloud deployment
skills last year itself I was able to
crack a great job of X Tech as a
associate software engineer
I got a 50% salary hike as well as far
as my experience with the course is
concerned I'm completely satisfied with
the course and the
platform I really like the back end and
front end classes especially back end
since I was not aware of backend
development I learned multiple things
and I'm very happy with the go I will
definitely recommend this go to my
P